remotely piloted aircraft are getting
new attention amid reports Iran shot
down a u.s. Navy drone last month and
the u.s. down an Iranian drone last week
many of the drones the US Air Force
flies overseas are piloted from a
military base right here in the United
States Janet shamlian got a rare
behind-the-scenes look at those
operations and she joins us now from
Creech Air Force Base in Nevada so Janet
what's it like out there
glad good morning well Creech is deep in
the desert it's about an hour's drive
from Las Vegas and when you get here
this is what you'll find a hangar filled
with the aircraft's fleet of drones that
by the way is a term the military does
not love they prefer remotely piloted
aircraft but whatever you call it the
reaper this plane specifically which has
been in the headlines lately has become
an all-star in the military's war on
terror hours before first light engines
spool up final checks are made and the
reaper is out to the runway but the team
at the controls is a mile away in a room
that's effectively the planes cockpit
this is the aircraft they're flying
across the Nevada desert they'll soon be
navigating a similar Reaper in the skies
above terror hotspots around the globe
without ever leaving the state this is a
base at war every day these metal
containers have been turned into
air-conditioned cockpits and the pilots
who are inside them are training to fly
missions all over the world
600 pilots and 350 sensor or camera
operators work in teams around the clock
averaging six airstrikes and a thousand
combat hours every day the act of taking
a human life the act of supporting guys
on the ground is as stressful as it was
sitting at 16 regardless of the distance
in between the two air frames major
Bryce is a combatant in the sky eight
hours a day so even like right now we
could turn the laser on I could turn in
and we could fire another missile
sometimes dropping health IRA missiles
or precision-guided bombs on high-value
targets our job is to be in the mental
model knowing that we could jump right
into the seat and something could happen
he says being close to home makes him a
better pilot even though I might get
home at weird hours I get to go home and
spend time with my wife and daughter the
missions themselves are classified so
this camera right here is able to
provide 360 degrees of rotation and so
are other capabilities of the Reaper but
here's what the Air Force will say the
planes are protected against threats
that could try to jam the satellite
signal between pilot and playing
as aviators patrol the skies without
ever leaving the ground it takes about a
year to train one of these pilots of
know France Australia Spain they all use
this facility to train their RPA pilots
and the UK's Royal Air Force actually
stations its pilots here they live here
and they use the cockpits to fly their
planes out of here are their drones out
of here Gayle
Wow Janet thank you very much really
interesting first of all I didn't
realise how big those things I was
thinking - yeah and the second thing is
you hear that guy saying goodbye to his
daughter and then he steps into that
cockpit they have in a desert he's at
war yeah I mean the space between your
bed at home and a war zone is like that
and I've always been in awe of how young
our servicemembers are they are so
talented they were so good at their jobs
but many of them are just in their 20s
yes no difficult I'd much rather see a
young person who knows what they're
doing and someone who's you know of
advanced age they're good at what they
do they're very good at what they do at
all ages to be honest with you